In a purported breakdown of the first two-thirds
of The Rise of Skywalker's plot, Reddit user
JediPaxis has claimed that something major
goes on at the end of the movie's second act.
Specifically, someone Star Wars fans said
goodbye to just a few years ago will supposedly
make an epic, unexpected return.
A rumored crucial part of The Rise of Skywalker
could involve the inner turmoil of Adam Driver's
Kylo Ren.
The former Ben Solo has spent his adult life
striving to emulate Darth Vader, by rising
through the ranks of the First Order and pledging
allegiance to the Empire.
His path has been pretty dark throughout The
Force Awakens and The Last Jedi, but some
fans have theorized that the new Supreme Leader
could be redeemed in The Rise of Skywalker.
How might that happen?
"I had a blast today.
I really learned a lot, and people are gonna
love the new me."
According to some fans, none other than Kylo's
father, Han Solo, played by Harrison Ford,
will return in The Rise of Skywalker and offer
his son a chance at redemption.
The moment allegedly happens after Kylo and
Rey engage in a tense lightsaber battle, during
which both Force-sensitive fighters can feel
that Leia is dying.
This heightens their emotions, and pushes
Rey to grab Kylo's weapon and drive it through
his chest.
She tells Kylo that she will never be like
him before summoning her newfound healing
ability to save Kylo from death.
Afterwards, Rey steals Kylo's ship and Darth
Vader's wayfinder device to head to Endor,
leaving Kylo broken and defeated.
It's here where Han Solo reportedly appears
to Kylo as a vision and tells him that it's
never too late to return to return to the
light and make the right choice.
Kylo is said to be moved by the conversation
with his late father and decides to become
Ben Solo again, thus returning to the light
side.
The idea of Kylo Ren stripping away his dark
persona, reclaiming his birth name of Ben
Solo, and turning to the light side is an
intriguing thought, but will it actually happen
in The Rise of Skywalker?
Similarly, will Harrison Ford actually circle
back to the Star Wars franchise to play the
character whose son killed him in cold blood?
Neither are out of the realm of possibility,
given that some pretty wild stuff has gone
on in the Star Wars universe before.
As fans have heard at least 100 times since
news of Episode IX first broke, the movie
will bring the Skywalker saga to a definitive
end.
Could this final film showcase the last fight
between the First Order and the Resistance,
as well as a redemption for Kylo Ren?
Star Wars has brought dead characters back
as force ghosts and visions before, so it's
not unreasonable to think that Han would resurface
as a vision to his son, offering him guidance
at the lowest point in his life.
Still, Kylo did straight-up kill Han in The
Force Awakens, so there's something to be
said about whether Han is the person Kylo
needs strength from.
Another thing worth considering when pondering
the possibility of Han Solo returning in The
Rise of Skywalker is whether Harrison Ford
would want to be a part of the film.
As Ford told Jimmy Kimmel, he'd been pushing
for Solo to die for almost 30 years, so that
may mean that he considers the death the ultimate
culmination of the character.
"I argued for 30 years for this to happen.
Finally, I wore them down."
Still, there's really no better way to bring
him back to the franchise than by helping
redeem his wayward son.
There's also the chance that this alleged
plot breakdown holds no weight and what actually
happens in The Rise of Skywalker isn't even
remotely close to what's rumored.
Kylo could stay on the dark side, Han Solo
could stay offscreen, and a completely different
sequence of events could unravel.
Fans will simply have to wait to learn the
truth when The Rise of Skywalker arrives in
theaters on December 20.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.